the shower hasn't changed much in over a
hundred years it's mostly just a pipe in
gravity and a lot of waste the average
American family uses 400 gallons of
water a day 70% of that comes from
indoor use and most of its from the
bathroom add to this a punishing western
drought and rice year on record and
clearly something has to change
a startup called Nebbia has one idea to
cut water waste by 70% the company
started working on the water-efficient
showerhead five years ago in Mexico City
to make the new device they look at old
technologies used in the aerospace and
automotive industries the challenge was
to split droplets in even tinier
droplets while still keeping the water
and surrounding space warm what we're
doing essentially is atomizing water so
we're creating millions of tiny little
droplets that create a surface area
that's about a hundred times greater
than that of a regular shower so create
this immersive and enveloping experience
of water the water savings was the key
component that's why we started working
on this and then we realized that if
you're going to save water in a shower
it also has to be as good if not a
better experience Nebbia went through
dozens of prototypes they use PVC pipe
and nuts and bolts and while that might
have looked ok in a steampunk contained
bathroom Nebbia wanted to create an
iconic brand something that consumers
would see as an aspirational lifestyle
product so they turn to San Francisco's
box lever for design box lever took
maybe as ruff nozzles and smooth them
out ultimately settling on a design that
mimics the shape of the showerhead spray
a halo the handheld wand has the same
look only smaller the bar that connects
the showerhead to the wall behind you
includes a front piece that smoothly
slides up and down so adjusting the
height is easy our perspective on design
is really about creating a lasting
design we always think about what's the
long-term impact whether it be
environmental whether it be something
it's an heirloom we're always thinking
about these variables and how to make
design time
neviah held a wildly successful
Kickstarter campaign and there's
currently an estimated delivery date of
May 2016 the $400 device is one of the
most if not the most unique showerheads
on the market and that's because it
works unlike any showerhead I try to
have a nubby a shower and it's well it's
different
instead of pounding droplets like in a
normal shower it's almost like stepping
into a warm fog or a mist it's really
Airy
but it works and yes you can walk your
hair